Tim Bon Temps ESPN NBA writer asked 20
coaches executives and scouts from
across the NBA about what happened and
what lies ahead after what happened in
this crazy offseason the topics range
from who's the best player in the league
to which team will win next season's
championship and Tim joins us now Tim
good to have you back what was the most
surprising answer you got with this
entire survey that's a good question Dan
I hadn't really thought about that I
guess to me the thing that surprised me
the most was the number of people who
said Kawhi was the best player in the
league not that I was surprised he got
the most votes but when I kind of came
up with this idea a few weeks ago I
didn't really expect Kawhi to get that
much of a percentage over the bone
really anybody to get that much based
off how tight the MVP race was all year
and the fact that you know there has
been a lot of discussion about who the
best player in the league was but but
the way he played in the playoffs you
know I think that kind of just
overwhelmed people into choosing him as
know I think deservedly the guy that
right now has title at best player in
the league why didn't anybody have the
Lakers winning the championship this
year I think because that's probably the
right way to go in terms of forecasting
things I
I think the Lakers have obviously with
LeBron and AD that's you know what's
good one-two punches you can find in the
league but even though there's summer
you know bouncing back after not getting
Kawhi was you know probably went better
than expected
given how long it took for him to make
its decision and how many guys decided
quickly I think they do have a lot of
flaws on their roster and even with
those guys at the top end I think when
they get in the playoff series against
say the other team in LA or you know
some of the other top teams in the West
I think those flaws are going to be very
difficult for them to overcome in the
Western Conference well what flaws are
you talking about
they don't really have very many players
who can guard anyone you look at their
roster they really only have I would say
two guys in AD and Danny Green that are
above average defensive players at this
point
LeBron obviously can be but you know for
the most part he is not getting the same
kind of effort that he used to at the
other end of the court and they just
have you know because of the nature of
their roster they've got a bunch of guys
that are on you know minimum contracts
or small contracts not just leads to
guys not being that good I don't think
Ridge on Rondo at this point is that
good I don't think JaVale McGee at this
point is that good we'll see if DeMarcus
Cousins can take another step forward
from where he was last year but coming
off the Achilles injury that is a
question mark you know really other than
Danny Green in Kyle Kuzma who is a kind
of a really nice offensive player but as
cautious defensively you know they've
got a lot of guys who come into the
season with questions so they look again
LeBron and ad is a great place to start
but to say that they have you know
they're a favorite to even get out of
the West I think with the amount of
strong competition around them Utah
Denver Houston you know obviously the
Clippers I think combination of their
flaws and the strengths of the other
teams I can understand why people would
choose to pick somebody else to win the
rest and in this survey of coaches
executives and scouts from around the
NBA nobody had LeBron as the MVP that
surprised you know I wouldn't say so
because because again you know LeBron is
going to be 35 he's coming off the first
significant injuries career he played I
think the least games has ever played in
the season I'm sure but least games has
ever played the season in his career
right so if you're trying to project
forward for next season and you're asked
to pick who's the best player in the
league I think it's reasonable to not
pick him right and even it's funny even
in not even though the Lakers got no
votes for winning the West or winning
the title and even though LeBron didn't
get any votes for being the best player
in the league LeBron came up several
times probably
five or six people if not more said I
you know LeBron's in the next spot you
know they decided to go another
direction and a lot of people said well
the Lakers are going to be good but they
decided to fix it so you know the
Clippers or somebody else so it's not
like it sound like the Lakers got you
know no respect or no thought from
people it's just that when you're making
a binary choice you know when you look
around the league you know LeBron is in
kind of a similar situation to where the
Lakers are as a team in that the fact
that people don't think he's any good at
this point or that he isn't really good
but if you're choosing between him and
one of these other couple guys or
between the Lakers and one of these
other couple teams people tend to go the
other way
Tim Bon Temps covers the NBA for ESPN
joining us on the program what do you
think the game plan will be for Russell
Westbrook and James Harden with the
rocket find another basketball maybe
that might help I am genuinely
fascinated to see what that team looks
like you know there was a lot of talk
two years ago about whether Chris Paul
and James Harden could play together
that experiment on the court I think
probably went about as well as it
possibly could of and and frankly went
better than I thought it was going to at
first but Russell Westbrook for Brett
presents a lot of different challenges
in that he also brings some different
strengths he's you know he's incredibly
athletic he can fly but on the court
you'd think that Houston will be more of
a transition team when he has the ball
in his hands than they were before
but when you look at Mike D'Antoni
system and guys who need to be able to
shoot right Russell Westbrook is not
exactly a prototypical fit in that the
Rockets would say hey if he's going to
shoot 30 to 33 percent on open threes
that's fine he could just jack those up
and we'll take you know 50% effective
general percentage from him on those
shots but you know I don't know how
that's going to go i bowl team James
Harden are not good off the ball I'm
curious to see how that goes
you know their faults going to have to
work harder in those aspects they're
both going to have to find ways to
impact the game more than they have when
they don't have the ball on their hands
it you know it's going to be a really
really interesting experiment
and one that it sounds like both those
guys have you know went to went to the
Rockettes and say that hey we'll make
this work so you know at this point to
me the thing that makes it really
interesting is after they say that it's
on them to actually make it work and now
we'll see if they can but here's my
philosophy with the Rockettes why not
just have Hardin start go seven eight
hard minutes and then I bring in
Westbrook and and so I just have him
going against that second unit
I do load management with both of these
guys and I know they love their numbers
but I would just I would just be coming
at you in waves if I were the the
Rockettes what do you think I I think
that that probably was going to happen I
think to your point about them I don't
think they're gonna play like twenty
four minutes each you know but I think
if you look at the way the Rockettes
handle James Harden and Chris Paul to
your point one of them was on the court
for 48 minutes right yeah and I'm sure
that's what's going to happen with these
guys and you know it wouldn't surprise
me if they kind of run things in a
similar way to what Brett Brown does in
Philadelphia right where he will take
out somebody four or five minutes into
the game like Joel and Pete will come
out I like the eight minute mark of the
first quarter and come back in at the
4-minute mark right and maybe won't be
quite that pronounced but I would I
would be very surprised if we don't see
some pretty heavy staggering with those
guys
and you know it to try to maximize their
time on the ball because no to your
point the one thing looking at Westbrook
that could be a benefit to him going to
Houston is he's never had a lot of
shooting around him and Oklahoma City
and if you put him on that Rockets team
with James Harden off the court and a
bunch of shooters around them and he can
just attack the rim then that could end
up being a really nice situation for
them in those minutes the James is on
the court I'll leave you with this Tim
Steve Kerr was critical of Anthony Davis
how he handled this should have handled
it quietly players should honor their
contracts which I understand but you had
draymond Green flirting with Kevin
Durant before Durant was a Golden State
warrior when he was under contract and
you had
Paul George a year into signing a
contract extension on Paul George day in
Oklahoma City telling Oklahoma City that
he wanted out I have a bigger problem
with Paul George than I do Anthony day
at least Anthony Davis there was some
transparency there so what do you think
of what Steve Kerr had to say that is a
really complicated topic that I could
probably talk about for an hour I think
what Steve would say I think to your
point is that Paul George did it quietly
and therefore the Thunder were able to
get a massive return for him Emily did
it quietly it was 24 hours where he'd
make this happen but I but listen I
think to your point I agree with you in
the sense that a it's rather rich for
the Warriors to be criticizing anyone
for how team building happens right in
the league and I think in general we're
just kind of past the point of no return
with the players like a kind of analysis
- the players are kind of taking the red
pill from the matrix and you've realized
it's kind of what what the system is and
that they have the power to exploit it
in in every way and the day that you
know the top five to ten guys really
control the league in every aspect but I
mean listen was the Anthony Davis thing
great for the league last spring no it
wasn't great in the sense that you don't
want to have one of your you know five
or six best players in the league not
playing for basically the second half of
the season but if you spin things
forward
you know if you look what the league is
now you've got stars all over the place
you got two stars on a bunch of teams
the league is in great shape and you can
go back all the way to 1975 if you want
when a Kareem abdul-jabbar went into the
box and said I want to play for the
Knicks of the Lakers trade me there Yeah
right so this is something that's
happened for Louis you're the league so
I don't know which this situation is
better Paul George Randy Davis or like
which one is a better or worse situation
for the team involved but at the end of
the day this is
the reality of life in the NBA and you
know whether it's Steve or anybody else
I think you'd think we just have to get
used to the way this is going because I
don't think it's changed in attention
Tim good to talk to you again thanks for
joining us anytime Danny Tim bon temps
he covers the NBA for ESPN for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]